the Joe Rogan experience there was an
article today where they've confirmed
that Huawei has some sort of third party
backdoor with a lot of their electronics
there was a lot of speculation to why
the United States was banning Huawei
from the major providers from you know
because they were very close to
releasing some and they have some
amazing phones and they were really
great used to use them yeah yeah just on
principle
in fact like one of my girlfriend she's
kind of sponsored by Huawei she's
European
wanted to take a selfie of me and I was
like I am there's no way that my face
could ever be you know in your phone
really tell me why look what is what are
your thoughts on it
oh wow way is is really another just
apparatus of the the main party the
government and you know I I really think
that Huawei is with respect to the next
era of the digital world is the next
Sputnik like it is the Sputnik issue of
our time and we should be doing
everything we can to to to not allow our
way to you know have this big market
share and the person who started it was
somebody that had a lot of party
connections to to though I think it was
in general or something and it's really
they really operate in a way that's very
opaque and you know anyone doing
business in China will have to have
connections to the government especially
when you're that big and because it's
it's a government that has such
totalitarian control over everything you
can expect that that whatever
information or that they would have to
answer to the government whatever the
government wants if you're willing to
put your privacy in the hands of an
entity like that you know go ahead but
know also that the Chinese government
has enacted all these mass surveillance
policies it's I just wouldn't trust
I just want to trust them so what is
different between Huawei and there's
many Chinese manufacturers of cell
phones and let's yummy yeah it's it's
the it's the government connection is
the only one that has that deep
government connections well though the
founder at least was general that much I
know
and just a lot of party connections and
you know just it's also heavily
subsidized by the government which is
one of the ways that China has been
competing kind of unfairly in global
markets right when you have you can
drive out innovation in the United
States by by making sure that your local
version is so competitive from prices
that they can't match you so in a way
it's like a form of economic warfare
which is one of the the issues that
Trump has really pushed back on its the
China trade issue mmm-hmm and he's been
criticized by about that do you think
he's correct on China yes on China yes I
do think he's correct he's been pushed
back on it's interesting because I think
the Democrats were a lot more you know
protectionist when it came to trade
right there the Republicans and the
libertarians always like free trade free
trade everything like you know let's
globalize the world or was the whole
Thomas Friedman position when he wrote
about it in Lexus and the olive tree
that if we globalized the world that
economic you're icky you lift a lot of
people out of poverty or you're economic
pie grows but your politics shrink that
was idea right no two countries that
have McDonald's would fight a war or
something like that that was his theory
hmm
and in the case of China obviously that
didn't happen right like the part about
the politics changing it was a quote by
a Hanuman protester he said if the free
world hasn't changed
China China will changed the free world
whoa and if you think about what
happened with the NBA yeah the whole
daryl morey yeah explain that because
that was shocking to me because the way
they were capitulating to China I was
you know I was a little stunned because
it was so open yeah and to explain what
happened so Daryl Morey who was the GM
of the Houston Rockets he tweeted out
basically a little picture that that
showed that he supported Hong Kong
protesters and the Hong Kong protesters
have been added since July of last year
20:19 they have been protesting the
incursion of Chinese control into their
supposedly autonomous region China
promised them that there would be two
systems one country two systems after
the handover in 1997 from the British to
two to China they slowly kind of eroded
that in many ways and their freedoms
have been kind of you know diminishing
over time the straw the straw that broke
the camel's back was actually this
policy that they passed this law they
passed that said that anyone can be
extradited to China for trials basically
it was after a case that happened the
criminal case and the Hong Kong people
knew that this law if it goes in effect
basically gives the Chinese government
legal right to disappear kidnap anyone
and bring them for trial in some sort of
Kangaroo or show trial in China and that
has happened so booksellers it's always
the booksellers in Hong Kong have been
kidnapped because they were publishing
these lights inside our accounts like
dirty secrets of the you know the CCP
whenever there was a leak because the
the Chinese Communist Party is huge the
political euro was huge and so there was
a book seller called causeway books and
they were publishing all these like
accounts from within the Chinese
Communist Party and the owner of that
bookshop one day just disappeared and he
ended up in China I was basically a
forced kidnapping and he he was released
I think he was you know he did his jail
time and now he's sending up another
book book shopping with Taiwan but but
that law basically would just have
allowed China to do that legally this
time so the Hong Kong youth were up in
arms they you know they were tired of
all their the ways that their way of
life had changed since the British
handed handed it over and all you know
in a way they were kind of pining for
the good old times the good old times
when they were under a colonial you know
in English colonial master which was one
of those like moment for anyone on the
left and so Daryl Morey tweeted this out
and of course you know how big the the
China market is for the NBA right like
all these players have contracts with
them in fact the who
Rockets had a lot of contracts with the
Chinese CCTV for broadcasts they also
had like merchandising opportunities
Snickers that were made there and that
caused a huge huge outcry in China they
were just like oh he's disrespecting us
and they were able to force him to
basically make a groveling tweet that's
it I'm sorry for hurting the feelings of
the Chinese people and then like all the
other some NBA players actually came out
and and you know kind of took the side
of the Chinese government like oh wait
who are we to you know they kind of like
did this backpedal thing when when
they're so strong on other forms of
activism here like the NBA when it came
to the North Carolina the bathroom bill
you remember like the they were they
were always on the side of the woke but
then when it came to the China Hong Kong
issue they stood with the biggest
oppressor
[Applause]